welcome to the show I am going to talk a
bunch today about what's going on in
Venezuela and talking about this issue
at all is sort of a Pyrrhic victory
because there's a contingent of the left
that is getting Venezuela just very
wrong and when I talk about it I feel
like I'm doing the right thing in the
sense that it's important to point out
when the left goes wrong but these
stories get relatively little traffic
and they do anger a bunch of people in
the audience and they even sometimes get
people to cancel memberships because
people get mad at me over what what they
see as me getting the story's wrong but
it just would not feel right to ignore
the Venezuela story right now ignoring
it would be a missed opportunity to talk
about some really serious geopolitical
issues even if there are people in my
core audience that just flat-out
disagree with me I know every time I
talk about this some people do actually
say you know what there is a bunch of
nonsense going on with this issue on the
left and some people actually do come
around and change their mind so I think
that in the long term it is worth it for
me to keep talking about this and that's
why I'm just gonna jump right into it
today we had this questionably valid
re-election of Venezuelan president like
Nicolas Maduro
and after that the General Assembly
leader Huang hua though was established
as interim president with the idea as
provided by the Venezuelan Constitution
that if there is an election that is
perceived to be invalid the General
Assembly can appoint an interim
president and that interim president is
to oversee elections that are ideally
more fair or fair compared to the ones
that started the entire problem to begin
with I said when we started talking
about this a week or 10 days ago that
what ultimately happens is going to be
hugely determined by whether the
military stays with Nicolas Maduro or
abandons Maduro and we actually have
some news about that and I'm going to
talk about that a little bit later but
what I want to talk about first here is
flat-out how there are a lot of people
on the Left that are just missing the
boat on the foundations of this story
there
are too many leftists in the United
States and in some other countries who
are supporting Nicolas Maduro but for
different reasons some on the Left are
supporting Maduro because they've fallen
for his foe progressive rhetoric this is
sort of like the most romantic reason to
support Nicolas Maduro and many of them
also before Maduro were were equally
taken with Hugo Chavez both of whom
spouted very progressive sounding sort
of utopian socialistic stuff but the
truth is that they are authoritarians
who subjugate the basic democratic
institutions elections the press the
judiciary and others for their own gain
they are running kleptocracy Zinn effect
that's one piece of the left that
supports Maduro another piece of the
left that supports Maduro does it
because they believe to differing
degrees that the Venezuelan opposition
to Chavez and Maduro has from the
beginning bin American neocon funded
astroturf may be tied in with getting
oil from Venezuela now we could do an
entire hour just on that which I know
most of the audience doesn't want
although maybe I'll do a live stream in
more detail about just this issue but
here is why the left is misguided on
this and really needs to get it together
the right is already using Venezuelan
so-called socialism to attack the left
okay to attack actual socialism to
attack social democracy these are bad
faith criticisms from the right and
James Bloodworth points this out really
well in his latest piece for foreign
policy which you should read so the
right is of course going after the
Maduro regime in a way that is
advantageous to their worldview so that
then what happens is when the left
simply defends the regime we end up
losing even bigger because the left is
making the mistake of believing that
they are simply opposing American
imperialism or they're simply supporting
these utopian socialistic ideas by
standing by Nicolas Maduro
the regime but what they are doing in
effect no matter what they envision
themselves to be doing is defending a
brutal authoritarian even if you say
they're not actually defending Maduro
it's that they're just so opposed to
American imperialism or two wars for oil
or whatever the modern left still loses
when we defend Nicolas Maduro and this
is where we get to that term that I've
been using for a little while now the
Leninist left there is an American left
that is focused on anti-imperialism
particularly against the US Empire and
they end up supporting all sorts of de
facto dictators us-led regime change
around the world and in particular in
Latin America has been a disaster it's a
huge red flag when we see the American
neocon establishment want to get
involved in that not in America I
completely agree with you American
military involvement in replacing Maduro
in venezuela could be absolutely
disastrous but does that mean that the
american left should again take the side
of the people that are effectively the
domestic imperialists the Maduro chavez
regime nicolas maduro
domestically is doing many of the things
that the Leninist Left claims to be
opposed to the u.s. doing around the
world i can't support that and i hope
that you don't either even if there are
other countries supporting opposition
groups in Venezuela that doesn't change
that in Venezuela there are tons of
people who oppose the destructive Maduro
regime who are protesting for real a
huge risk to their lives
now the left will come in and say well
behold on its an american-led coup hold
on a second
Maduro has destroyed fair elections
Maduro has eliminated all sorts of
checks and balances you've got elements
of the left doing the exact same thing
with Assad in Syria and then they will
come in and say it's all for oil because
Trump simply wants their oil Trump may
want their oil I quite frankly don't
think Trump really understands much
about the situation there but the oil
companies aren't hugely into
American military intervention in
Venezuela they're pretty happy with the
status quo getting to refine the low
quality crude oil from Venezuela making
money off of it so the idea that there's
the sort of United Front of the United
States government and oil companies to
take Venezuelan oil and upend the the
status quo that's simply not true
you can agree or disagree with one or
both but it's not a cut and dry position
that the US government and oil companies
have a particular plan that they're all
in agreement with for Venezuelan oil so
that's also not a good argument so where
I end up is the same place as a week ago
which is that I'm a progressive I do not
support any of these authoritarians I at
the same time I'm against American
neoconservative interventions and I am
afraid that Trump will get involved that
doesn't mean that I support either
implicitly or explicitly Nicolas Maduro
Maduro and Chavez before him were
kleptocrats
just like Trump who governed or
themselves except that Maduro and Chavez
did and do enough redistribution and
rhetoric that sounds populist that
allows them to keep some popularity and
retain power it's not for me let's
suppose leaders who should be opposed
and let's vote for people in the United
States who won't do the types of
interventions in Latin America that
we're against we don't need to stand by
Maduro because we think maybe Trump is
interested in Venezuelan oil